je suis physicien théoricien donc mon
discours va être sensiblement différent
du précédent et pourtant vous allez voir
que peut-être vous allez trouver
quelques ressemblances c'est un peu une
surprise pour moi mais vous allez voir
je suis spécialisé en physique théorique
en physique fondamentale et je me suis
demandé dans quelle mesure cette
discipline qui nous parlent de la
réalité du monde mais de la réalité du
monde ce que c'est que l'espace le temps
la matière la lumière le glide et
caetera et des notions qui finalement
sont atteintes d'une manière assez
difficile avec des expériences des
observations très délicate et c'est pour
ça qu'on parle de physique fondamentale
parce qu'il s'agit de questions
fondamentales est très difficile à
aborder
et je me suis demandé dans quelle mesure
cette discipline pouvait nous aider et
nous guider dans notre vie personnelle
dans notre vie de tous les jours et je
suis arrivé à plusieurs réponses et j'en
ai choisi une pour vous en parler ce
soir il y en a d'autres il y en a
d'autres par exemple unique et très
intéressante c'est de s'interroger sur
la créativité de ces scientifiques qui
nous ont donné des résultats
remarquables comme einstein ou newton
galilée et bien d'autres et c'est
extrêmement intéressant extrêmement
enrichissant et quand on s'interroge sur
les raisons de cette créativité
oh bien sûr il ya pas de miracle n'y a
pas de réponse toute faite mais on
retrouve certains des aspects que l'on
vient d'entendre mais c'est une autre
c'est un autre aspect que je veux
évoquer ce soir c'est la leçon que je
voudrais tirer c'est finalement qu'il
faut se méfier de notre intuition il
pour reprendre ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure
se méfier de nos impressions première
alors c'est pas tout à fait dans les
mains
circonstances il s'agit pas tellement de
rencontres avec des collègues ou des
personnes que l'on est amené à
fréquenter mais se méfier des
impressions d'une manière générale
et quand on veut comprendre ce qui se
passe autour de nous et pour cela
j'avais choisi un exemple qui va être
tirée de la physique fondamentale de la
relativité générale qui est une théorie
dont bien sûr de vous en vous avez
entendu parler et que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas dans tous ses détails et
je vous en dire quelques mots
j'aurais pu choisir aussi une autre
branche de la physique théorique qui
s'appelle la physique quantique qui est
plein également de surprises mais donc
j'ai choisi ce soir la relativité
générale et un thème plus précis qui est
celui des notions temporel et vous allez
voir que la relativité générale nous
envoie un message qui est très clair
c'est que le temps n'existe pas et
pourtant le temps c'est quelque chose
que nous manipulons tous les jours qui
nous permet de nous retrouver de se
donner des rendez vous que nous
utilisons sans arrêt dans notre pratique
dans tous les aspects de notre vie
et pourtant la physique nous enseigne
que le temps n'existe pas et je voudrais
faire une précision qui est aussi très
importante parce que quelquefois et moi
même je viens de vous le dire
la relativité la théorie la relativité
générale nous déclare que le temps
n'existe pas mais en fait c'est pas tout
à fait ça c'est que c'est l'observation
du monde très précises par les
physiciens par leur expérience par les
observations qui nous enseigne que le
temps n'existe pas et c'est ensuite la
relativité générale par l'intermédiaire
dalsh d'einstein qui en a été le
créateur c'est einstein qui par cette
théorie nous donne une interprétation du
monde qui tient compte de ce fait établi
que le temps n'existe pas c'est à dire
c'est pas la relativité générale ou
n'importe quelle théorie qui va vous
dire spécifiquement le temps n'existe
pas mais c'est l'observation du monde
l'expérimentation sur le monde
la recherche que font les physiciens de
manière pratique et concrète qui nous
dit le monde tel qu'on découvre est
incompatible avec l'existence du temps
et ensuite la relativité générale
construite par einstein va nous donner
une description du monde qui prend en
compte ce fait mais qui je répète est un
fait d'observations infecte d'expérience
le temps n'existe pas et pourquoi j'ai
choisi ce sujet si parce que évidemment
l'existence du temps qui est tellement
et imprègne tellement nos musiques nos
existences c'est quelque chose dont nous
avons eu l'intuition c'est quelque chose
qui nous semble évident le temps existe
évidemment on a envie de dire eh bien
pourtant non l'observation du monde nous
démange alors pour commencer avant de
rentrer dans le sujet de la relativité
générale
je veux simplement vous exposer un
résultat d'expériences très précis
j'aurais pu en choisir beaucoup mais je
vais vous en donner un qui est très
précis qui a été accompli il y a
quelques années et qui va illustrer le
fait que le temps n'existe pas qui vous
en donnera une une expérimentation si
vous voulez concrètes
donc il s'agit des horloges les plus
précises que les hommes et jamais
construit ce sont des horloges atomiques
ce sont des horloges atomiques très
compliqué des systèmes très compliqué
qu'on appelle dans ce cas particulier
des fontaines optique pour des raisons
que je ne vais pas vous expliquer ici et
ces horloges sont extrêmement précises
c'est à dire si vous avez une montre et
que votre montre ne va pas avancer
disons d'une seconde
retardée d'une seconde en une année bon
vous allez être je pense assez satisfait
moi j'ai jamais une montre aussi précise
bon et bien là les horloges dont je vous
parle on peut être sûr que sur les 13
milliards d'années d'existence de
l'univers elles n'avancent ou ne retarde
pas de plus d'une seconde
donc c'est la lose la plus précise que
l'on n'ait jamais pu construire et c'est
même difficile d'imaginer mieux
bon alors les physiciens ont construit
des horloges comme ça et si vous les
laissez l'une à côté de l'autre et bien
elles sont parfaitement synchronisés
quand vous les mettez à l'heure vous les
mettez évidemment à la même heure et l
indique toujours toujours toujours la
même heure tant qu'elle reste l'une à
côté de l'autre mais vous prenez une des
ces horloges et puis vous l'amenez
lentement à l'étagé au dessus dans le
bâtiment vous la laissez un moment à
l'étagé au dessus et puis vous la
redescendre et et lorsque vous la
redescendre et et bien son indication ne
coïncide plus avec l'indication l'autre
horloge alors que ce sont deux horloges
parfaite
alors bien sûr elles vont pas être
décalée d'une seconde d'une minute mais
d'une petite fraction secondes mais que
leur précision permet de mesurer
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire tout
simplement que il y a une chose qui est
sûre c'est que puisque les deux horloges
marche à la perfection
et puisqu'elle donne des résultats
différents si le temps existe il y en a
au moins une des deux qui ne donne pas
le temps qu'ils ne mesurent pas le temps
et si vous prenez 10 horloge différentes
que vous leur faites des trajets
différents dans le bâtiment encore une
fois c'est quelque chose qui a été
réalisé simplement en montant les
l'horloge à l'étagé au dessus quelques
mètres plus haut vous aurez des avec 10
horloge du résultat différent avec son
horloge sans résultat différent et il
n'y a aucune raison de penser qu'ils en
est une qui indique le temps et l'autre
qui indiquerait autre chose alors on
pourrait imaginer il ya plusieurs temps
il ya le temps numéro en qu'indique
l'horloge numéro un le temps numéro 2 et
mais à ce moment là vous allez être
obligé d'imaginer que des temps et en a
deux
si vous avez 10 horloge il y en a 10 si
chacun à son horloge
il ya combien 7 milliards de d'habitants
sur terre il y aura 7 milliards de temps
différents etc etc
il n'y a pas de limite donc il est
impossible d'imaginer que le temps et 7
milliards de facettes comme ça et
finalement la seule manière de s'en
sortir et c'est ce que font les
physiciens et ça a été confirmé par
d'expérience d'autres types que je n'ai
pas le temps d'exposer ce soir mais
finalement la seule vision cohérente du
monde c'est de dire le temps n'existe
pas alors qu'est ce que mesure une
horloge et bien une horloge mesure
finalement une durée c'est pas du tout
la même chose c'est-à-dire l'horloge
mesure la durée qui s'écoule depuis le
moment où on la met à l'heure
jusqu'au moment où on va la lyre et
finalement le message que nous avons
d'après cette expérience c'est que entre
deux moments bien précis et bien deux
horloges deux personnes vont mesurer
vont vivre vont éprouver des durées
différentes
le physicien paul langevin qui était un
des amis d'einstein dans les années 1920
et qui était un des premiers à avoir
compris la relativité générale a imaginé
une petite expérience de pensée dans ce
genre une expérience de deux jumeaux
deux jumeaux qui évidemment quand il
naît snes au même endroit et ont le même
âge et puis un des deux jumeaux va à un
moment donné partir faire un voyage dans
l'espace et retrouver son frère jumeau
et bien qu'ils aient le même âge au
point de départ disons le moment où ils
s'embrassent avant que le jumeau
voyageurs montent dans son vaisseau
spatial et le moment de retour lorsqu'il
se retrouver bien il y en a eu 1 qui a
vécu par exemple 20 ans et l'autre qui a
vécu cinquante ans donc ils vont se
retrouver dans la situation où ses deux
jumeaux qui évidemment au départ avait
le même âge et bien il y en a un qui va
avoir 40 ans et l'autre 70 ans
bon c'est quelque chose qui n'a jamais
été réalisé pour des raisons pratiques
parce qu'il faudrait que le jumeau
voyageurs à y faire un voyage très
rapide avec une fusée qui le soumettent
à une accélération qui serait
insoutenable
mais si vous voulez c'est une
transcription à notre échelle de cette
expérience d horloge qui a été réalisé
et donc la conclusion
encore une fois c'est que le temps ne
peut pas exister parce que chacun des
deux jumeaux pourrait dire - la durée
que j'ai vécu c'est une mesure du temps
et comme elles sont différentes il peut
pas y avoir un temps unique pour tout le
monde et ça donc c'est le message de la
relativité et cette relativité
d'où vient-elle vous savez que c'est une
création de ce fils
un génial qui s'appelait albert einstein
et pour en dire deux mots bon albert
einstein est né en 1889 et en 1879
pardon et en 1905
alors qu'anne stein était employé dans
un bureau des brevets alors qu'il
n'avait jamais été dans universités
alors qu'il n'avait jamais eu contact
avec la faculté avec l'enseignement
supérieur universitaire il a écrit dans
cette année 1905 trois articles qui ont
chacun des trois d'une manière
différente révolutionné la physique
alors que c'était pas du tout un
chercheur professionnels comme il y en
avait déjà à l'époque et comme il y en a
encore plus aujourd'hui
alors ça c'est un des grands mystères
comment ce jeune homme en dehors des
circuits a pu avoir trois idées aussi
génial bien entendu les historiens les
psychologues tout le monde s'intéresse
beaucoup à ça mais je laisserai de côté
pour ce soir mais parmi ces trois
articles y en a un qu'on considère comme
le fondement de la physique quantique un
autre qu'on considère comme une
confirmation qui dont on avait vraiment
besoin à l'époque de ce qu'on appelle
l'hypothèse atomique
c'est à dire la conception de la matière
qui est faite d'atomes ce qui est notre
conception aujourd'hui est le troisième
article fondait cette théorie de la
relativité
parce que einstein a découvert cette
chose fondamentale que le temps n'existe
pas il n'a pas découvert de la manière
que j'ai indiquées précédemment
parce que les expériences que je vous ai
mentionné qu'ils ont été faites il ya
quelques années n'était pas du tout à la
portée de la technologie de l'époque il
l'a découverte d'une autre manière par
des questions de synchronicité que je
vais pas vous exposer ici mais qui ont
été analysés bien sûr par les physiciens
qu'on m'explique dans les cours de
relativité qui ont été analysés aussi
par les historiens parce que comme
einstein est il venu à tout cela bon
c'est extrêmement intéressant également
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce
qu'einstein l'a constaté en premier
c'est que la notion simultanéité ne peut
pas exister
alors imaginez que vous ayez un ami un
collègue et cosmonautes et qui se trouve
sur la planète mars et vous avez envie
de vous poser la question à l'instant
précis où je
parle qu'est ce que mon ami est en train
de faire sur la planète mars
à l'instant précis où je parle bon bah
vous pouvez lui poser la question ont
l'âme c'est que si vous me posez la
question voulu envoyer un message par
exemple par radio le message 28 minutes
donc au bout de huit minutes il va
recevoir la question qu'est ce que tu es
en train de faire il va dire je suis en
train de décapsuler une bouteille de
bière
mais quand vous allez recevoir la
réponse huit minutes ce seront encore
écoulé donc il aura largement bus à
bière et de toute façon vous n'aurez
nous n'aurez pas la réponse de ce qu'il
faisait au moment où vous avez envoyé le
message
donc il ya un problème de communication
comment se synchroniser comment savoir
ce que mon collègue de la planète mars
fait au moment où je parle et einstein
s'est bien rendu compte qu'il y avait
une difficulté
alors cette difficulté il a essayé de la
résoudre
il a essayé de se dire est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer une procédure qui va
être forcément plus compliqué que cet
échange de signaux que je viens de
mentionner est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer une procédure me permettant de
savoir ce que fait mon ami en ce moment
par exemple moi je des capsules une
bouteille de bière
bon il a imaginé un processus comme ça
sur lequel tout le monde s'est mis
d'accord et bien j'applique ce processus
qui est un peu compliqué mais qui est
tout à fait réalisable en pratique et
j'arrive à la conclusion
pendant que je des capsules ma bouteille
de bière mon ami sur mars est aussi en
train de décapsuler sa bouteille de
bière le problème c'est que si mon ami
sur mars est en train de faire
exactement la même chose que moi
et de se demander qu'est ce qui fait au
moment où lui des capsules sa bouteille
de bière il va trouver que je suis en
train de finir la vidéo est donc
absolument impossible de se mettre
d'accord et il existe aucun moyen sur la
notion simultanéité c'est à dire moi je
vais penser que homo mange des capsules
ma bouteille
mon copain des capsules sa bouteille lui
il va penser que au moment où gilles des
capsules sa bouteille
j'ai déjà quasiment fini ma bière et il
n'y a aucun moyen de se mettre d'accord
c'est donc une impossibilité de la
simultanéité et c'est donc aussi une
impossibilité du temps parce que si le
temps existait si par exemple on pouvait
dit
il est actuellement 20 heures dans tout
l'univers
la notion de simultanéité il serait très
bien défini il suffit de dire à l'autre
regarde ta montre qui indique le temps
si on indiquait le temps et dis moi ce
que tu as fait à 20h et moi je sais ce
que j'ai fait à 20 heures j'ai des
capsules et ma bière bon et dans ce cas
là on pourrait se mettre d'accord sur
une réponse
donc si vous voulez l'impossibilité de
se mettre d'accord sur une réponse qui a
été trouvé par einstein puits qui a été
confirmée de manière multiples depuis
nous indique que non seulement la notion
de simultanéité n'existe pas mais la
notion de temps ne peut pas exister
en revanche la notion de durée existe
parfaitement ce que mesure une horloge
encore une fois c'est la durée qui s'est
écoulé pour cette horloge précise depuis
le moment où la mise à l'heure est donc
finalement le fait que pour deux
horloges qui vivent deux histoires
différentes
parce qu' on a une qui allaitent âge au
dessus les durées ne coïncident pas ça
nous étonne bien sûr ça nous empêche de
faire ce qu'on fait d'habitude c'est à
dire de dire on prend toutes les durées
qui coïncide tout est de dire on appelle
ça le temps maintenant s'il est dur et
une coïncident plus eh bien on peut plus
appeler ça le temps dans la vie courante
bien entendu comme les différences dont
je vous parle c'est des microsecondes on
s'en fiche complètement
et donc ce que nous appelons temps ça
vient du fait que toutes les durées que
nous vivons par exemple entre le moment
où nous entrons dans cette pièce et le
moment nous allons en sortir nous vivons
chacun des durées différentes mais
différente d'une fraction de seconde
donc tout se passe comme si c'était les
mêmes durées
donc on va dire on a tous vécu la même
durée on appelle ça le temps et pour la
vie courante
ça marche très bien mais on sait
maintenant on le sait avec la physique
des particules qui vont très vite avec
les rayons cosmiques avec
l'astrophysique avec la navigation
spatiale avec les télécommunications
spatiales avec le système gps grâce à
tout ça des millions et des millions de
fois chaque jour on vérifie que le temps
n'existe pas et ne peut pas exister
alors quelles conséquences dans la vie
de tous les jours et je finirai par là
bon la première c'est que donc comme je
voulais dit il faut se méfier de ses
intuitions de notre intuition qui nous
dit ballottant évidemment ça existe nous
méfier des premières impressions et puis
aussi ça veut dire sur nous mêmes qu'est
ce que nous sommes nous mêmes
qu'est-ce que est mon ami cosmonautes
parce que je ne peux pas penser à mon
ami cosmonautes à l'instant présent
parce que je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait à
l'instant présent et je n'ai aucun moyen
de le savoir il faut que je pense à mon
ami cosmonautes comme quelqu'un qui vit
une histoire qui vit une histoire de son
passé avec son présent avec son futur
qui décrit une histoire et moi même qui
suis je
si je veux me définir je ne suis pas
seulement celui qui vous parle en ce
moment je suis celui qui a pris le train
tout à l'heure je suis seul incident
technique
c'est pas grave je suis celui qui a fait
elle voyage il y à quelques temps qui a
écrit un livre qui a rencontré untel ou
untel je suis celui aussi qui va
reprendre le train demain qui va faire
tel autre voyage donc si je veux me
définir moi même je ne me définis pas
tel que je suis un instant à l'instant
présent
mais je définis ce que j'appelle ma
ligne d'univers c'est à dire la
continuité de tous les événements que
j'ai vécu de ma naissance à ma mort et
ça c'est moi et si je veux savoir qui
vous êtes et bien il ne suffit pas de
vous observez dans ce fameux dixième de
seconde dont on parlait précédemment
parce que j'aurais eu l'impression
biaisé mais il faut que je sache qui
vous êtes depuis le début il faut que je
connais votre ligne d'univers autrement
dit vous vous n'êtes pas un point dans
l'espace à un moment donné mais vous
êtes une ligne et cette ligne elle n'est
pas dans l'espace mais elle est dans ce
qu'on appelle l'espace temps et donc
finalement ce message fondamental qui
paraît un message relativement abstrait
de ces théories de la relativité qui
nous disent non on ne vit pas dans
l'espace et dans le temps mais en vidant
quelque chose de plus compliqué quel
espace temps je vais pas vous et définir
aujourd'hui ce que c'est que l'espace
temps mais finalement ça s'applique
aussi je pense à notre vie de tous les
jours et peut-être il nous faut la halle
et un peu contre notre intuition c'est à
dire que ce qui existe à savoir moi même
nous mêmes vous même mais aussi
n'importe quel objet un objet c'est pas
quelque chose qui est un instant donné
dans le
se passe mais c'est quelque chose qui
est une histoire dans l'espace temps et
donc si on veut comprendre la réalité du
monde
il vaut mieux parler en histoire qui se
déroule qui se déroule non pas dans le
temps mais dans l'espace temps parce que
le temps si on veut être stricte
il y en a plus et donc nous sommes tous
des histoires tous les objets que nous
rencontrons que nous côtoyons sont des
histoires et donc je pense que notre
vision du monde aussi bien en physique
fondamentaux doit s'inspirer la physique
fondamentale et dire que nous vivons
dans un espace temps contrairement
peut-être à notre intuition
merci
[Applaudissements]